isn't it beautiful
look at this cutie well enjoy it while
you can
because if we don't act right now in
less than
80 years we won't be able to appreciate
it anymore
your great-grandchild will only
experience it in
books or by watching nature videos
isn't that scary scientists predict that
the ocean's oxygen levels could drop
three to four percent
by the year 2100 as that happens
oceans will undergo drastic losses of
biodiversity
and entire ecosystems could be wiped out
why is oxygen disappearing
how could this affect us
and is there anything we can do to stop
this
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the oceans lose oxygen
oceans losing three to four percent of
their oxygen
might not sound very threatening but
it's a big deal
these massive bodies of water cover most
of earth
we know that about 200 million years ago
oxygen was depleted in the oceans this
led to a massive extinction of species
with oxygen levels dropping in the
oceans again
could we face the same loss of ocean
life
and if you like to eat lobster shrimp or
fish
will you have enough for any to eat in
the future
it's brook trout hope you like fish
i love it speaking of food
farmers use fertilizers that are rich in
nutrients
rains wash them into rivers which carry
them to the oceans
in coastal waters and estuaries these
extra nutrients
increase plant and algae growth and this
is called
eutrophication this causes an
environment with low oxygen
called hypoxia and when the oxygen is
gone
the water is called anoxic that
leads to fish kills and dead zones that
can't sustain life
it can increase the ocean's acidity too
can you see what's happening it's a
massive domino effect with
a deadly outcome and sea life
and biodiversity are being hurt by it
already
even today as the ocean's oxygen levels
decline
some male fish are producing sperm less
capable of movement
and low sperm counts are not going to
save our species
[Music]
wow it really inks in here
some species including the humboldt
squid are moving to new feeding grounds
where the water is oxygenated
and that's a big problem the humboldt
squid
used to inhabit the waters from south
america to mexico
sometimes california but
now they've been found off the coast of
alaska
and so are the fish they feed on
the squid are now competing for food
that
tuna and sharks typically feed on in
this area
this is disrupting the delicate balance
of the food web
and will lead to massive amounts of fish
loss
and death and here's another problem
some sea creatures
would surface from the depths looking
for oxygenated water and
eventually they would die caught in
human nets
big fish would disappear first as they
need more oxygen to survive
as this continues we'd likely have to
say goodbye
to dolphins whales and all of the
beautiful mammals that currently live in
the oceans
and as we say goodbye to big fish like
tuna many people would lose their food
and
income commercial fishing industries are
already struggling and
would eventually close if you live on an
island
there's a limited amount of room to grow
crops and
raise animals so many nations depend on
the oceans for food
what would happen to japan indonesia the
philippines or
the caribbean islands if there were no
more fish but
what can we do to help our oceans well
global warming is one cause of
deoxygenation
reducing our greenhouse gas emissions is
one thing we can do
and need to do to protect our planet's
ecosystems
and the overuse of fertilizers in our
agriculture
is something that we should reconsider
as well want to know what else is
affecting our oceans plastic yeah
tons of plastic is in the oceans and if
we won't have
fish to eat what would happen if we ate
plastic
well that's a story for another
what if